We have a voicemail number on this show.
Here's an interesting voicemail about something
people have written to me about before my
disclaimers.
Let's take a listen to what the caller has
to say.
Hey, David, I've got a New Year's resolution
for you.
Yes.
How about no more of the disclaimers for idiots?
All right.
You don't have to explain every time that
Chris Wallace is not our friend.
The Lincoln Project is not our friend Fox
News or not because blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
If people on the left are too dumb to ever
accept that maybe someone outside of their
tribe has something reasonable to say from
time to time, do you really want them to be
a subscriber?
So this is completely fair.
So they're referring to yesterday I did a
segment where Chris Wallace said one thing
that made sense and I kind of gave this disclaimer
where I said, I'm not saying Fox News is trustworthy.
I'm not saying these are our friends.
All I'm saying is Chris Wallace said one thing
that that makes sense.
The reason I do those disclaimers is for my
own sake, it's actually selfish.
I'm being selfish when I do it.
And I'll explain why.
If I talk about different plans for health
care and I say there's Medicare for all and
there's this other type of money, here are
different types of plans.
If I don't clarify, I'm not saying I want
for profit health.
Right.
If I don't clarify that, I will get no exaggeration,
100 emails clogging my inbox from people saying,
David, how dare you, how dare you?
Support for profit health insurance.
So the reason I give the disclaimer and I
say, hey, I'm telling you something that exists.
I'm not advocating for it.
I will get 100 emails when I do the disclaimer.
I only get 40 now.
It's merely agreed that I don't it's not even
greed.
It's a concern for my own inbox.
That's why I do the disclaimers.
I agree that it's sad.
I do, but it is what it is.
And if you saw what was going on with my inbox
every day, you would also understand it.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman dot com.
I'll speak to you on the bonus show.